all right let's put this on first
[Music]
what is that what the [ __ ] is that
welcome back to the worst way to play
cyberpunk 2077
we're playing it on xbox one base
with no updates so this is version 1.0
meaning for those of you who don't know
cyberpunk at its launch had a
rocky rocky start so it's going to be
difficult
we're expecting bugs we're expecting
crashes
but uh that's the challenge in the
nature of the game right jake
it is and here we are taking a sad sad
shower because
that's that's what v is right now so
what's the
kind of the goal post for this episode
how far do you think we should go
i figure we can just keep doing a little
bit of the story
uh okay and then maybe we can mess
around a little bit
uh when we once we've gotten our
eye uh-oh
oh no just locked up for a little bit
we're good
sliding around a little bit i mean i
thought those were roller skates i
thought they were roller skates too
or heelys yeah he leans
nope didn't open the door it's okay
right through the door
oh there it is you didn't see anything
cannot go in
oh it's over here no it's not
no this looks familiar oh god i got a
setter okay
did i just get locked out i don't know
did you miss a window
yeah maybe i think i was supposed to
follow him but i stopped to look at that
other guy
all right hold on let's reload i guess
okay
so that marks our first reload yes
oh no all the way back here oh no
oh no wait i don't wait see if it open
oh it opened thanks
what because you went to a menu
[Music]
oh let's pet the cat
and pet the cat again can i no
oh lord oh it froze no
continue no we're good it's freaking
freezing in here mr bigglesworth
you might feel a little discomfort at
first word vision
low contrast glitches
uh how does it look feel all right to
you
cool
yeah pinching it's missing like there
should be like a gray part too
hey kitty pet the cat again
oh well i think there's a fight here you
get involved in
oh nice
they're not really doing anything
easy pickings
level up
cool oh this is ncpd we probably want to
fight them
what you slept on a banana
what happened oh what are you
getting hit by a car i
did drive by you running too fast hey
guy
[Laughter]
why is everyone ready to kill me
my god that guy's doing a whole lot
hell of a guard
[Music]
i can't what i don't know what's going
on
is there just like no
enemy ai what did you trigger
wow i have no idea what just happened
i'm nervous as to where this is going to
load us
oh we're good no we're not
how far back
we're where we started no
where we started this auto save just
doesn't work
real close
so so he just goes through the door
so that you missed an opportunity here's
what here's what i will do
okay okay
it worked again
hey pet the cat
it's like groundhog day groundhog if
groundhog day was 10 frames a second
or it's like the matrix was like deja vu
what'd you say
i'll never forget that scene
he's so stiff why are we still here
just to suffer no lipstick just every
night
i can feel my legs
it's a really comfortable chair
those lockups happen so often
whoa it's really bright out oh
oh oh god
they seriously just don't do anything
for like it's like you were waiting for
like their ai to load in
oh or even just entirely their body
oh
oh wow wow
are they below you is there anything
below
sorry did you see that last
last second umbrella popping no that's
what oh that's what you hit was an
umbrella let me check the map
let me check the map
i said let me check the map
oh there it is um
yeah why not
come on a little bit a little bit hell
of an eagle there it is
we're sorry please remain on the line as
we value your call
just gotta wait a little bit he'll be
here soon person this is a person isn't
it
he'll be here soon he's just taking oh
there he is
what this looks pretty
ridiculous what is that
i don't know all right hold on let's put
this on first
okay see what we're working with here
all right let me oh
[Laughter]
i wasn't either i had to look away
because i
actually physically hurt that spandex
was tied around his
junk oh my god that that like actually
like physically affected me
ow
all right i got a new ride hey taxi
oh
there's no one driving is it a smart car
maybe
ah is that it nope oh
we live another day show me what you got
i mean you got the perks in the right
place right
oh yeah look at that
oh boy is he done he's not no more i
give
up was that it
you had enough like your brother or
hungry for more
that ain't my brother what wow
i mean you rocked him man you got all
your perks in the right place
i guess so okay after that beat down
we're gonna
call it for this episode uh stay tuned
next week for another one on the worst
way to play cyberpunk
2077. thank you guys for watching
thank you jake and yeah have a great
rest of your week see y'all bye
you